ma part le côté l'une des grandes fêtes
musée fait majeur dans l'église
orthodoxe et surtout la pentecôte c'est
comme on le connaît également dans
l'initiative la descente de l'esprit
saint la promesse de dieu aux hommes
assez fidèle la semaine dernière c'était
il ya eu le jeudi de l'ascension où
jésus est élevée dans le ciel et la
promesse qu'il avait faite à ses apôtres
arrive justement à ce moment là le
l'esprit c'est descendra sur eux en
langue de feu les impôts sont réunis
dans la chambre haute comme dit dans la
bible
est-ce que ça descend sur eux en langue
de feu l'esprit saint promesse de dieu
ce qui permettra aux apôtres de
d'accomplir ce pourquoi jésus est venu
les enseigner la guérison des malades
et puis bien sûr la propagation de
l'évangile d'instruction et
l'information de nouveaux prêtres de
nouveaux pasteurs pour guider le
troupeau
comment va se passer la cérémonie nous
commencerons par un artiste à l'esprit
saint de nature de vie à cathy sts faut
se rappeler ce que ça veut dire
à 4 ans grec veut dire debout donc la
prière debout pendant une à cathy ça
dure à peu près une demi heure donc
d'abord un cristal et suisses
invocations l'esprit saint de nature de
vie ensuite la liturgie se déroulera de
manière classique les couleurs l'utile
liturgiques ont changé comme vous l'avez
vu je porte des vêtements de couleur
verte
ce la couleur que l'on porte pas dans
les effets de la célébration de la
pentecôte et l'évangile parlera
essentiellement du dernier message
de jésus le message les la manière dont
il a prié lui-même le message qu'il a
donné aux hommes le message le comme il
a prié son pays l'a dit tout ce que tu
m'as donné à 3 et tout ce qui est à moi
y'a 3 et leur dis donc
une semaine après le l'esprit-saint vos
visiteurs a simplement